the show's fantastic and i will just say
that karen has
a lot going on this season
yes she does it so do you know you've
seen eight of them so
they sent me you know all ten um
and i refuse to watch them uh i wanna
watch them as the audience
watches them i'm a weirdo like that and
i like to kind of have the experience of
seeing them and interacting with people
and
seeing the full production on my screen
sure i mean but you were there you know
what's going to happen
i was there i was i yes i was
emotionally yes i have a lot of stuff i
want to talk about
for all mankind but i put i mentioned to
a few people i was going to talk to you
and someone sent in a question and so i
wanted to make sure i could ask that
let's do it um i believe his name is
eric kripke
um and he said hey chantel
long time fan first time caller i'm a
huge fan of yours
you're an amazing actor and yet i keep
killing you in my shows
what's my sickness i mean his sickness
is everything that you watch
in the boys i mean i don't know how
graphic i can be
but basically the fleshy thing that
chokes somebody
in season two is definitely part of his
sick brain i love eric
and um i just adore him i am
i i said a very long time ago it is very
hard in hollywood to find loyalty
and that man has has been loyal through
and through
and um and does incredible
incredible shows so i'm lucky to be on
his radar
uh i know that they're getting ready to
start filming season three is
do you know if you're any sort of any
flashback or anything
that do you think i can tell you that
come on i i can't i can't
how about how about i'll just say eric
and i have had some correspondence
lately
you know i understand he's not he's not
really a first-time caller you know
exactly look i mean that show anything
can happen but let's get into why
i know right anything um but that show's
fantastic but so i i love for all
mankind and i definitely want to jump
into
that for people who are um looking
forward to season two
what what can you tease people about it
nothing this is the worst part is like
my favorite is when they send
the list of like do not spoil and i was
like oh so nothing there's
literally nothing um you know in in
trying to craft some sort of teaser i
think that
i've landed on you it's really
interesting
doing time jumps because i remember
ending season one thinking oh my gosh
she's lost all this identity and
everything that she's
loved and who is she gonna be
and you know my mind goes to the worst
case scenario and i'm like she's gonna
prostitute herself and become a crack
addict and like
you know it was like all these very
extreme awful ideas that i had and thank
god i'm not a writer
and they handed me the scripts for one
and two
and i was still shocked that
um that it seems as though karen has
changed so much and i think that she's
finally living a lot more in her truth
as a lot of the characters are um and
discovering
more of who they are and their truth
which is
really interesting um for like a season
two premise
but she's not really that different um
in in her innate nature taking care of
people is just who and what she is and
she finds a way to do it
on a bigger scale and um
it was it was interesting to to dive
into um where karen is at which is kind
of a
another midlife crisis
uh yeah i wish i could get specific i
can
call it that right
i can say karen has a lot going on this
season you were given a lot i mean i
have thought she had a lot going on in
season one and then season two came and
i was like
oh this this girl just does not get a
breather okay
uh when you see in the scripts that you
are going to be eating spaghetti and
drinking beer
are you like uh god damn it
or what is it like actually filming
those scenes
um it's me writing and being like hey
guys do we have gluten free because i'm
celiac
and so everything that karen is eating
and drinking goes against
everything i can have um of course we're
drinking
you know colored water and the spaghetti
they had to try to find one that was
gluten-free but look the same
um you know eating on camera is the
etiquette classes my mom gave me as a
kid
i no longer exist um and so there were
a lot of takes of just cracking up
laughing as
you know noodles went flying and you're
trying to say lines and it was
um i know it was from ron moore's
childhood and
that part was really cool to play but it
is not easy to eat spaghetti
gracefully and carry on conversations
completely i mean i have a lot of
friends that are actors and they tell me
that you know the eating and drinking
scenes
between doing your dialogue hitting
continuity
it's just it's a lot harder than people
think
it is and we have a lot of of eating
when it comes to the baldwin family um
and so it's always a task to be like
okay what am i going to eat off this
plate that i can
eat for 30 takes and you know still do
without making a mess
completely um when you for this season
and even for the first season how much
did you know
or how much had they figured out about
the arc of karen and the series how much
did you know
and how much is it sort of like you
getting it script by script
i would say 70
to 80 percent is script by script i know
a few
anchors within a season um
like big major things i found out pretty
early on
uh in season one what was going to
happen with our son and then very
quickly had to like
forget that i knew that that information
was there
but i didn't know how it was gonna
unfold and i didn't know how it was
gonna end
that's literally all i knew for season
one
season two i i knew a few
a few more anchors because they wanted
to talk me through their thinking of it
um and because i think there was some
trickiness in playing it you know in
season one a lot happens
to her and in season two she's
making choices that that are the reason
things are happening
to her and and in her life and so i
think that
to navigate that required a little bit
more knowledge
um and a little bit more crafting which
i appreciate
uh i like to know things it's easy for
me to forget them because i
just try to stay present when we're
shooting but um
but yeah we don't get to know a whole
lot they i like in season one the scenes
with wayne
who's played by lenny incredible i don't
think there were supposed to be as many
of those but for whatever reason when
they saw us together they felt inspired
so they wrote more of them
um and they're very organic in that
process and open to it as writers and i
love that like if they see something
that makes sense and they can kind of
feel inspired by and keep writing they
do what actually
is your favorite storyline that is not
your own
in this show
um my favorite story in season one or
two
and one probably i would like two but
i'll take one
okay but i'll i'll just say i can say
who um in season two it's gordos
i think that he has emotional
physical like there's a lot of of
transitioning happening and i i just
adore michael and i
i marvel at his talent um i have from
day one i watched him in patriot and i
was like oh
i get to be on a show with him um i just
think he's
he's incredible um and in season two i i
i like that deep dive of complete
transformation
and uh so i was very envious of of him
getting to do that
um and in season one
um i love molly cobb
i like her her demeanor i love
that she's totally opposite of karen
very free open spirit
but also like a little rougher on the
edges and
i just i think that it was a really fun
character for me to watch
on that note i gotta go i'm just gonna
say congrats on the series
can't wait to watch the last two
episodes when they send them
i know i can't wait for you to see it
thank you so much nice to talk with you
have a great day